you have people watching you lie Tina
you haven't a reputation to protect all
right which way all right are you Bros
with me Oh Ola doula stuff oh wait I'm
confused
gingka Lana cough cough ah Lana Brinker
Lana
Oh Tula Duff I like this wimpy day all
right
and then here fine and then just play
hey naked people don't please Wow what
are you doing payday Jesus Christ I've
got so many dead people something bad
happened here or good guns if you like
that kind of stuff I'm just saying I
don't know I I don't know what that was
I know he feels weird I feel like you
can't see me I'm not used to having my
the orchid is near and then ground -
what the orchid is in the air bro and
the grantor but I think you already seen
them I hope it was funny bro forever
Martin you will never look dim nor
pre-lit what what is this Martin you're
talking about are you cheating with my
bro Nespoli what is this what is this
this is a clue I don't understand
this is a clue I don't need it come out
of here
all right there's that thing I guess
let's look many side genitals maybe
we'll find something I don't know
nothing they were all our idea blade all
right well tell acting all right where
is the fauna bag yeah that is a bug gang
the question is have you been here maybe
we have maybe yes we have yeah all right
let's check the other place then hey
wait I want to try this have you bro
seen them Nisha trailer they find stuff
on alike in this basket yes that was out
how I was born I was born out of that
basket hey what is this I just in the
back how could I'm your dad for me bow
give that to my face and says it
disappointed all right this would be
they where I need to check all the rooms
and I'm big [ __ ] Rock Janet why would
you scare me what's gonna I forgot about
the dog oh my god I hate demon dogs
Daymond I guess Oh God those were the
days I remember I like I don't know not
many subscribers back then
hello doggy I'm glad whoever made this
mob honored why is it dead pigs did he
ate my pig disguise I'm out of here
Damon doggies alright that's locked
let's continue this way Petey all right
more advice but shots for Jennifer I'm
gonna leave you there Sakana
key machine room key Oh Alice Bailey
what which one is the fake one I don't
know all right let's do it
I don't trust you but 10 minutes I don't
they can't I'm sorry father but they
can't be - I try to hit that button then
I am their Safari of course did you meet
an impostor much all right let's take
this soon - I just bring the fun all
right
it's the game lagging or is the shaft
lagging please tell me because I need to
know all right I will read this note for
you while you figure it out bidding all
right one day in the morning is this
beautiful house the seller told me it
was house of a man called Patrick he
killed by he was killed by someone
whatever I think this house is good for
a bro so I let you this awesome house
pity your best friend Martin Martin with
don't everybody look at what are you
talking about I am your best friend baby
don't really make it out I am laying
down because I am sad good alright let's
go to the machine room girls and boys
the video is lagging no I don't post it
I mean it doesn't like for me juice yeah
it's all fine good I'm glad because we
have a lot of bros here and i put a lot
it thank ya think
oh wow almost 7000 you've never to talk
do you
I'll then I'm so happy let's gossip pity
all right good good thanks you guys for
helping set up the steam it's really
cool that you can see my face I'm really
hey what is this I think this is last
room Bros I don't trust this pearl eh
I'm gonna put you that no actually no I
need some shot we'll do this together
we'll finish this together put it all
right Cody I'm sorry
Preedy I forget your name sometimes okay
oh yes yeah he's on top oh wait he's on
all right let's finish this castle sorry
I don't just good now just callosity
there what is this place
did I use the key yeah that should be
something here right oh it's here
probably up up up nothing as it's
possible I guess if it looks here maybe
yeah I think ends here
can someone confirm that it ends here I
mean read a note you got the thing and
the thing only thing you forgot the
corridor where the bang gang bang was
all right let's go to the gang mine then
I suppose where's the gang bang doesn't
end here okay but where am I gonna go
then I had tell you what are you gonna
go
don't worry pity the pros they don't
they think they know actually okay they
probably know better than me wait behind
the closet should I go back
I am at by the game bang did I miss
something here
the bonesaw way the [ __ ] is the bone saw
guys you can't die no oh God
okay okay pity be quiet don't make
noises
you always make noises alright let me
look for you if he said he's that you're
screwed
okay alright it's going there maybe we
need to go where here Jesus Christ you
were scared weren't you alright let's
not get too close what is he doing but
he's coming up is looking at you pity
does he see you
I don't wanna all right
Hey I don't know where's the bonus uh
can someone spam this sad droid the
bonus sighs I'd appreciate it
hey I can go here ah this is where the
bone sighs oh yeah what are you doing
get that up here I described what is
this gross wife is dead but I can hear
that voice has fabulous boys
she's so pretty imperium the shadow took
her to the dock
she was so young why sometimes I listen
to her sing
why sometimes additional input sometimes
wife and I want to die my last word
Patrick oh poor Patrick so any the bros
for the gangbang is all right come fern
bros what are you scared what happened
today
they say it was Larry you're safe
good a signet ring sir but this is
police why did I waste my only tinderbox
how whatever
hey Scully Ellis pity no one remembers
me I was actually a first bro
I was what I'm kidding hey what is this
funny polling hey all right
what is it I feel shadow in my house I
feel danger the death the called I'm
scared
Patrick stuff
hey icky cool good progress buffing your
motto so what are you doing this is no
time for break that Jesus Christ I need
to practice my job
you always thank you so much time busy
yeah I guess bluey was my first bro
you're right all right let's continue
this is mob Wow all right I can't free
the rock Wow 7000 bros that's amazing
I'm so proud of all right fine
I just want to check to where the lock
might be in here nope all right [ __ ]
this custom store is bigger than my bow
Wow okay we've been in here I don't know
if you looted everything no we haven't
been in here
hey oh yeah awesome hey lad no no no no
no where is my daughter
where did she go it was so dark and cold
the shadow car that no it's impossible
give me my daughter I don't do anything
not Leena ethic stuff right I don't
understand really to be honest but
that's okay all right where's fauna
there we go
did I go in here and don't come out sick
these are yeah I've been in here for
shizzle my settle daesil
Wyatt Nana nerd nerd none and I know my
own now nananananana nananananana now
hey that one is locked down it's locked
he doesn't work all right
all right someone said Iron Maiden room
probably like five million times let's
check that I remain in room I don't
remember whether I will spell right
thing there's a gangbang
mmm and I all you brother like good is a
good life since we can help you and that
everyone is trolling me okay thank you
thank you thank you so much yes Christ
Wow okay that's not that yeah I would
love to see blue in an amnesia I'd be
awesome
I missed blooming he was such a trooper
Louie all is sticking with me freakin
Diamond Dogs don't ask them these doors
are all locked right yeah maybe it's
here yeah I'm pumping it up on the boat
I got bone stuff for you Petey
I did it for you yeah you know what I
deserve you should fix me up on a date I
want to find man I mean girl I'm not gay
or anything but I mean if you want to
romance I mean that's cool I mean I'm
open for suggestions just because I'm
not one side it doesn't mean I'm gay I
mean it's different pick that up for me
I was using as a dildo all right fine I
know how you use a knife as a dealer
don't ask questions alright I'm palm
okay all right you can go pity you can
go I don't buy you mean Pig all right so
now we use the bro saw brochure really
bone saw on the freakin this cursor is
called feed by the house I think I miss
a note oh no oh now then world is ending
alright let's use the bone saw don't
know hey I picked up a posionous client
all right
I all right mara I miss the key why stop
darling my name's missing statins maybe
I didn't work
nope didn't work either
thank you for that maybe here hi mr. noo
2x lat
you need a banner to go to the lab and
you will see a blue light after this go
to the fireplace to finish the potion
nothing to excite all you need burner go
to the lab where the [ __ ] is allowed by
Elmo look at note I guess let's just go
here sick if I miss something
ok fine I'll spin the [ __ ] wheel
because apparently I works hmm yes this
is amazing oh my god this solves
everything thanks for suggesting it yes
yes how could I not think about this
Jesus Christ
some of you gross I'm sorry really
you're drunk
alright [ __ ]
poisons Glenn share mode activated I
didn't check this falls and maybe
there's something in the closet
I know oh wow
oh holy [ __ ] you're such an idiot Vinnie
I want to kill you now
I should seriously consider killing you
alright let's go to the door I was like
wow why didn't anyone tell me
spin the wheel dude you must spin the
wheel
no I must not spin the wheel it does
nothing
Jesus kinda kills on one of you you're
freakin drunk bastard this is summation
be drunken of something it's not cool
or maybe you shouldn't I don't know I
mean you gotta work tomorrow or school
ok
there should be a locked door here
somewhere Jesus Christ
nothing low oh here this birthday yeah
sorry I don't know what that was alright
I am stuck what are you doing alright
let's finish this this is the laboratory
finally ok bro I want to explode the
slime that's what she said hahaha
actually maybe now the door next steps
you need an orchid very I already have
it I already got it bro I got it
I found myself you broke through you
should live soon so that we can help you
ah I'm glad thank you so much I'm just
joking obviously all right just follow
sets cup the orchid put it in the burner
make the liquid and boil it your best
friend Dean Martin what oh is this a
Martin Bellamy who is trying to break
our bromance
all right fine let's just put dark in
here doesn't work fantastic
we need to spin it out that's all right
that's the wrong way
no you're doing it wrong really spin it
the other way what why don't you do it
then all right fine I'll do it i am
stefano okay I'll get down to my house
dogs I don't trust guys it's a fireplace
maybe this is it umph umph umph umph
I'm so pumped yay yay a pope yay yay I'm
stuck all right Rudy I'm proud I'm proud
of you I'm gonna burn myself
just for you you can eat me if you want
you know I am a pig after all I'm quite
delicious
you know if they're I'm proud to be
eating my you you know now if you want
to you can kiss me this is a goodbye
kiss you know because that's normal
a lot of people like goodbye kisses I'm
one of them is nothing gayer any things
I just love goodbye kisses all right
let's finish this [ __ ] mud dude all
right
all right where's the pond where I keep
puttin so follow the fella no no how
would that man what yes
whatever one hour if you bros would help
me then I got damnit the wrong way oh
wow all right when I finish this I'll do
ask answer a couple questions and then
I'll pay what you bros suggest me to
play all right sounds good yay huh
all right let's finish this
alright I'm proud of you I'm proud of
Thank You mr. Sharon hey Daffy golf I am
Here I am stefana its final let's finish
this
yes
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you